nearly a decade after the global
financial crisis JP Morgan Chase
chairman and chief executive officer
Jamie Dimon has emerged as one of the
most sought-after voices on banking and
the global economy I sat down recently
with Diamond in Detroit Michigan to talk
about the Motor City's economic recovery
helped in part by JP Morgan's 100
million dollar investment in the city to
discuss whether the strategies used here
could be replicated elsewhere without a
mayor like this I think it would be a
total waste of time and even though he
won't be a member of president-elect
Trump's cabinet I don't think I'm suited
to be Secretary of Treasury Dimon gave
his take on where President Trump can
affect real change
fixing corporate taxes immigration trade
all done properly will have faster
growth in America and we can fix their
problems that's all coming up in this
special bloomberg businessweek debrief a
conversation with Jamie Dimon let's talk
a little bit about some more recent news
first I'm sure the audience is as
interested as I am you have been there
was a lot of speculation about you
potentially going into the
administration as Treasury secretary was
that a job you were interested in did
you turn that job down I've always been
quite public about I don't think I'm
suited to be Secretary of Treasury I
love what I do I'm not ready to do
something else and I to America just
doing what I'm doing well there we go
that's that's the answer so when I look
now as recently as September when I look
back at when you were talking about sort
of what you thought the next
administration would be and this is
before I knew the outcome of the
election you said you thought it would
be very difficult for Wall Street guys
to get confirmed and to get in and now
we look at sort of the landscape we have
we have several Wall Street figures some
of them you know very well including
Gary Cohen from Goldman Sachs Rex
Tillerson from Exxon Mobil Steve
minuchin when you're looking at that
cast of people what do you think they're
going to bring to the administration
that's different what's new that they're
going to bring in terms of experience is
this a good thing yeah so obviously I
was dead wrong about you know I could
see a Wall Street person in washing
anytime soon but you had a complete
upheaval the Republicans are in charge
and the Republicans have not been
anti-business the way you've seen the
Democrats largely be anti business for
years I think if you are going to be a
president you should have the best
people sitting around the table I think
it's a mistake for the American public
to Costin be told that if you work for
oil company work for a bank you work for
this that that automatically makes you
bad you want the best team and so you
know honestly I think it's a good thing
so I think a lot of these people are
very qualified people who want it a tree
'its are going to want to help the
country then I can try to help their
former company that's not what they're
going to try to do they're good so these
are people deep knowledge that hopefully
will do a great job and do you think
that now when you look at that sort of
shift in terms of Wall Street that this
is a bit of a reset moment for the
industry more broadly in terms of what
the American people are expecting or
what they're likely to see I think it's
a reset moment for how businesses can be
treated so I've always believed one
hundred forty five million people work
in America 125 million work for private
enterprise 20 million work for
government okay we hold them in very
high regard firemen sanitation police
teachers but you know if you didn't have
the hundred twenty-five you couldn't pay
for the other twenty so I think business
is a huge positive elements of society
and for you know for years it's been you
know beaten down as if there are
terrible people or something like that
so I think it's a good reset Detroit is
a perfect example that you see where
civic society not-for-profits here
government business working together to
improve the lives of American citizens
so yeah I think the reset has a chance
to do the same thing if you can
duplicate in what you're doing in
Detroit all around the country you're
gonna have a huge Renaissance well let's
talk about that because you travel
around the country you travel all around
the world what we're seeing in terms of
this economic populism phenomenon part
of which sure of this election we've
seen it in Europe with brexit when you
look at this what is your diagnosis from
your travelers from your experience
about what is going on and what is
really driving this explosion that we've
seen this economic ank's that people
feel their dislocation from society
what do you diagnose at us so I think
you know I've heard obviously a lot of
people try to diagnose what happened why
the populism and all the things like
that if you actually dig into the
numbers it was an anti-immigration per
se there's a little fear that America is
changing too much but it wasn't they're
not anti immigrants most of us are you
know children grandchildren
great-grandchildren
grins and it wasn't even anti-trade but
I think the at the core of the matter
was a frustration and an anger because
of two things really that middle-class
incomes have really not grown for 15
years okay and you look at the fact I
usually when you hear facts like this
they're just dead wrong okay people
don't analyze them tax law changes how
people how things happen but this case
it happens to be true and the second one
is the low-skill think of unskilled and
the dirty unskilled and skilled has been
growing over time and that unskilled
really I have a hard time having what
you call living wage I think those two
things are true but what you need to do
is diagnose why it happened it didn't
happen because business is bad you know
and there there are a million reason
couple of Technology et cetera and there
are solutions you know solutions which I
would say around training work skills
initiatives or some of the fields we
were working on I would greatly expand
the Earned Income Tax Credit
so they've you know if you're making
eight nine dollars hour that the
governor will pay you three or four
think of as a negative income tax even
if you're single right now we do it for
mothers with babies we don't do it for
single men I gives you a job the dignity
or job a living wage it helps small
businesses it's not you know necessary
good for big business but I think it's a
wonderful thing to do for society so I
think there are solutions that you can
have I think fixing corporate taxes
immigration trade all done properly will
have faster growth in America and we can
fix those problems and you know
unfortunately a lot of people who talk
about fix those problems their answer
those problems they think they can beat
up on business that that's going to make
it better which is not and so when you
look at now you have been announced to
be taking on two roles you're going to
be chairman of the Business Roundtable
and you're going to be on a group that's
advising the president-elect after
inauguration on issues about the economy
and policy business policy when you look
at those two roles which are separate
what are the things what are the
initiatives that you think he's going to
need to tackle first and what do you
hope to advise him on what do you hope
to steer that direction toward so the
you know obviously anyone was president
you know I'm a patriot I've always off
my help I did to President Obama I will
present our Trump's I'm in this group of
15 people has not met yet and it's think
of the CEOs and a bunch of other folks
and and he want her as he wants it to be
about jobs and growing the economy so be
specific about
and hopefully you have really good ideas
not just a lot of people yappin ideas
the BRT is differ the beer the Business
Roundtable is you look at America we've
got the chamber commerce who advocates
on behalf of business large and small
and maybe it's got twenty five thousand
members
this is 192 companies pretty much
representing large companies but
remember these large companies represent
if you take the fortune 500 the S&P 500
something that half of all Catholic
spending to the United States okay and
they it drives a tremendous amount of
growth I personally think they are
fabulous citizens in this country they
are philanthropic we pay everyone gets
medical benefits they we take care of
our veterans we do education we do
schools we want to have the country
grows I think the BRT could take a very
proactive approach to help solve the
nation's problems and be part of the
solution that's why you know I took on
that challenge and but but it was about
very specifically we need corporate tax
reform we are driving capital and
overseas every single day and you know
any the government made a mistake to act
like the inversion was the problem the
problem is that our tax rate is so much
higher the rest of the world and the
rest world's been coming down and our
just a level and because of that
companies are leaving their money
overseas the reinvesting it overseas
they're buying companies overseas and
some of that permanent it's not coming
back and so I think the only question
how much damage is done before you
change it and every study shows that
reducing corporate tax rates helps lower
paid people and wages and so you know to
me we should solve that problem hoping
the new administration can do that
just ahead diamond sounds off on the
growth of populism worldwide they want a
wrecking ball brought to these
governments they want change and what he
expects to see on American immigration
policy and look and we're not going to
kick eleven million people out
you
[Music]
you also talked quite ho clear in recent
weeks and years about education
immigration and infrastructure and the
parts that those are going to play and
how much are you going to spearhead that
those initiatives so you know education
I mean I think one of the greatest
disgraces in this country is the fact
that large industry schools 50% of kids
don't graduate and high school and even
those kids you graduate are not
necessary job ready and you know I look
at that and say that's that's a crime
that is a disgrace that's America at its
absolute worst we are allowing that to
happen and these kids don't have
opportunity and they don't have the
opportunity that we all had at one point
in life and we have to fix it where you
hear the government talk about old times
they'll make it free make this free it's
not whether something is free it's
whether it ends up where you're properly
trained for a job so if you go to
Germany for example two-thirds of the
kids at 15 or 16 go to vocational school
they work with those vocational schools
work with the local businesses so they
get kind of think of they get a
certificate leads to a job and even in
New York City you probably even notice
just go visit it there's a little school
called Aviation not a little order I
think it graduates a thousand kids a
year or 500 kids a year aviation high
school kids travel from all over the
city they are trained in how to maintain
small aircraft electronic hydraulics
electrical systems when they graduate
$60,000 a year everyone gets a job you
can do that robotics coding accounting a
lot of healthcare fields and there's
another 20 I just can't even remember
the list that's what we should be doing
it doesn't mean you can't go to college
it just means that you get an education
that leads to a job it has to be done
with local business it's not a
government program and in fact you know
if it works the local business will kind
of pay for that and you do it here we
were I've been to focus hope and a bunch
of are you all doing it here so that
that is a fabulous thing that we can do
that can create opportunity people great
job for people and as you know that has
a huge amount of good social benefits et
cetera infrastructure we need to do and
you mentioned it an immigration there's
a great bill it's already been I think
passed by the Senate called the Schumer
McCain bill proper border controls of
course you want to control your borders
but allows educated individuals who
mostly went to American Advanced got
advanced degrees here in science
technology engineering
math stay and I think we should let them
stay and let them build their careers in
the homes something like 40% of the
companies in Silicon Valley or from
immigrants you know Russian Indian
German etc and and then have some kind
of path to citizenship and it's very
tough takes like 15 years that you're a
good law abiding taxpayer here but not a
documented immigrant that you have a
path that you become a citizen behind
everybody else and look and we're not
going to kick eleven million people out
so I think it's the rational reasonable
responsible thing to do I understand why
people want the border control first but
I think we should do that too so all
these things that could be done they
just haven't been done and it's a shame
so when you talk about immigration and
and you just said we're not going to
deport we're not going to kick eleven
million people out some of the rhetoric
that we've seen this cycle has talked
about these type of things is JP Morgan
are you or other businesses in the
Business Roundtable are they going to be
the voice that says look we need a much
more pragmatic solution we need a way to
keep the people we need a way to keep
particularly for the jobs that you need
it and frame this as an economic
argument as a growth argument as the
jobs are even so the rhetoric I which I
thought was terrible in the election I
go to JP Morgan Chase and you know kind
of the letter I tell them if you're
black Jewish a LGBT african-american or
woman would support you and that kind of
diversity just the way it did before
okay we're not that's not going to
change anything here and in fact I think
you see the rhetoric seems to have gone
away even the rhetoric about immigrant
immigration president elect Trump or I
think it's sounding a lot different than
Canada Trump you know has now said that
if you break the law we're going to
deport you and they estimated the 11
million undocumented that only 800,000
had broken the law
and by that is the current policy United
States President Obama deported 2.8
million people I think for breaking the
law so but absolutely the the the
business rather has already supported
immigration for that very reason it is a
pro-jobs Pro and it's also respectful
the fact is most people you know going
to get worried about immigration it's
not necessary that they don't like
immigrants it's more sometimes you look
into they're more afraid that the
American Way of life is changing so you
could be multi
cultural but still support the American
Way of life
remember Abe Lincoln we are here to
rededicate ourselves for this nation
conceived in Liberty and dedicated
notion all men are created equal this is
the only nation in the planet that was
an idea it was a vision
it was a value it was not a tribe okay
and so I think it's dead and a lot of
people want to make sure that doesn't
change and that some people are
confusing multicultural that somehow
we're going to change that we will
tolerate different religions that we
won't tolerate different opinions that
we won't tolerate Free Press and that
you know honestly so you could support
that and be multicultural no but when
you also when you travel in sort of
Europe where this is also a very deep
phenomenon we see it in Italy we see it
in Germany we see it in France we see it
in the UK to be sure obviously with
brexit do you think this is a temporary
phenomenon in terms of how people are
feeling do you think it's a generational
phenomenon do you think that it will
essentially weed itself out or do you
think this is a really permanent
movement of people who are more focused
on redrawing sort of national borders
national identity regrouping around that
in what has been a decade of constant
more than a decade two decades a
constant disruption across so many
stabling forces in their lives so
remember when you look at something like
brexit there were completely different
forces for brexit some were
anti-immigration some were prefer they
want open and free trade someone so all
these people voted for a whole bunch of
different reasons and I do think if you
go to Europe and part of Britain there
there is the same frustration on income
inequality about growth in wages about
lost jobs if you were to parts of Europe
25% so it's not not the UK not Germany
but 25% of people between 21 and 35
aren't working is that a sustainable
thing if you have another generation of
that so I think there's a legitimate
frustration about why is that how'd that
happen and a lot of it is government
policy by the way so there is
frustration a lot of you saw it in
America and you see overseas is I want
to change they want a wrecking ball
brought to you know these governments
they want change they weren't necessary
voting for a lot of things people said
they
want something very different they've
seen and a lot of us are sympathetic
with that we want to see something
different once things to be better and
again you Alton we have to have facts
analysis and real detail to make that
happen
you know populism itself can be very
disruptive disruptive to strut
distorting things because look at
Venezuela Cuba Argentina which is now
going the other way
you know I'm doesn't about Europe just
keep in mind but we talk about all this
disruption they've had you know since
World War two peace they didn't have
peace for the two thousand years before
that so there are benefits that people
are reaping with it maybe they forget
about it but but it's important to have
peace in Europe too when we come back a
look at Detroit's turnaround so this has
been a train wreck which you wish you
all knew was coming for about 20 years
and how the lessons learned in the Motor
City can benefit others
Oh
[Music]
we talked a lot about how getting things
done and how government policy is in
structured right now to actually get
things done let's look at Detroit which
is what we're hearing what you guys have
done with 100 million investment over
two and a half years when you talk about
this when Peter talks about it when
other JP Morgan talked about when the
mayor talks about it it's a lot about
non-partisanship that is what echoes
through is that people coming together
and then it not be driven by by policy
differences between people how does how
is that working how did that work here
was it just that it was in a situation
where that could work and you actually
see that being able to replicate it in
the sort of climate we live it in a more
national level so the Detroit effort
started when I actually sat down I went
to see least Saunders who is the heads
da if they ask me which of the Union
permissible workers who was saying
nasties about JP Morgan I walk in the
room I say leave what are you saying
that I said I don't know I don't know
why I was saying it I you guys are a
great company and he and I hit it off
and he started to tell me about the
problems of Detroit I immediately left
at me I called up Peters in the room so
it's really the people in this room
Peter Shearer and all the other folks
the room who did all the heavy lifting
but we knew a little bit about the mayor
so he had a mayor okay door to door a
white man and mostly black community got
elected and he was talking about what
what do you need in Detroit we need the
street lights on he got him on all
65,000 I first came there was 30,000 it
didn't work and the first city with LED
we need jobs we need affordable housing
we housing for commercial marks we need
training and skills we need a last night
we didn't think for the entrepreneurs of
color fund 30 businesses who were helped
by this fund and they're somewhere in
this room and they're doing training
trucking I think one of them worked on
your light project here so that was a
big thing that they did restaurants but
this mayor had this huge set of problems
and it isn't like people say what do you
what's the one thing you're gonna focus
on he to focus on all of them it doesn't
work to do one you had to get people
here to get Hope back he had to bring
businesses back at it build affordable
housing and they got training at schools
get the police the sanitation the
sidewalks and you end with the smile
this man with a smile set up all these
things
you know like we were done a bit kind of
the war room for the lights the war room
for the sanitation the war room for
constantly tracking it all and it's
working and it was because of the mayor
and the governor too by the way one
Republican one a Democrat and just to
know I don't give a damn about Democrats
Republicans okay that they were talking
about what is it what's going to work to
make this work for society and we were
all in but we didn't just come here and
throw money at it which is easy to do as
you know philanthropy could often be
wasteful the team came up and again it
was Peter at the team and asked what do
you need so they needed for example they
had 70,000 blighted homes they needed to
get rid of them but they didn't know
where they were and someone care with
his idea I forgot who and we funded it
to use your iPhones and iPads to take a
picture in geo locate every home you
knew now 10,000 blighted homes have been
shut down they can plan he started
selling home and something he has a
Mother's mobile phone right now
and then so we want to be an accelerant
we want to we wanted to get things
moving so if you can build a building
here get some people into it that helps
the whole community if you can start
that entrepreneurs that helps the whole
community if you can start so we try to
do everything kind of think of more like
venture capital helps us get going and
helps to get growing working with the
governor the mayor all the civic unions
the not-for-profits here you know a lot
of things that people hear you do on the
ground we couldn't possibly do but
partying with you you know with our
people we all said our people come so
we've had I don't know how many people
but we've had 68 people kind of working
on projects for 20 not for profits that
they need help so it we gave them data
analytics money advice consulting all
the things you need to get certain
things off the ground so it's been a
fabulous effort and and honestly without
a mayor like this I think it would be
total waste of time the mayor told me
say the 65,000 slight is going in
tonight actually said there's going to
be a an event so that's it's quite an
achievement
why is doing something like this good
business this is a good business issue
we're talking about good business why is
an initiative like this in Detroit good
business for JPMorgan as well as for
Detroit yeah so obviously there's
business it's not that we lack morale I
would do it for moral reasons alone but
there is good bit so we are the largest
bank in Detroit okay we are we were
National Bank
mm Oh Nova started by General Motors in
1934 in the depression most the banks
are closing General Motors said we need
a bank in Detroit that Bank merger for
Chicago bank one and then which merged
with the JPMorgan Chase oh here we are
the largest bank and consumers small
business middle market we Bank all the
major institutions the hospitals the
major companies here and the government
so it's an important town for us it's
probably one of the only towns in
America bill it really did not have a
Renaissance the 80s 90s and 2000's most
other major cities did and you know so
this has been a train wreck which you
wish you all knew was coming for about
20 years okay and it shows you the worst
part of bad public policy and you could
throw money at it and and unfortunately
took the train wreck almost to happen to
bring in a mayor with a vision and
skills and leadership skills to get this
done
so we once we saw that obviously is here
we can help the city it helps our
business stuff like that it could be a
shining example of the right way to do
things in society and and for us it was
a little bit you know if we do if we can
do this kind of here so remember we Bank
here we need a healthy vibrant bank this
is an extraordinary effort we could do
it elsewhere too and help these
communities where we are and I think
it's just good for society obviously
very good for business and in terms of
when you look at doing projects in
Detroit instead of building us out the
projects of a design very much to be
jobs and to center around economic
opportunity and expanding that and
making these neighborhoods a
revitalization where people can walk to
work or that they still have easier
access so that you know it starts with
the family it starts with a home it
starts with a job is that replicatable
do you think on a much broader scale
just even just the lessons that you're
taking out of Detroit yeah I mean if you
travel around the world and I get this
to travel around the world and see all
these things Singapore does it it's a
country when it form it was part of
Malaysia but it formed it was partially
Chinese partially Malay partial Indian
in his big chose languages a prime
minister came in with the same kind of
vision and strength to get it done is
its GDP is now higher than than the GDP
of the average American okay the Prime
Minister is pretty tough he made the
molar in English so it could become a
back-office for companies he made sure
the streets were clean when he when they
have a lot of affordable housing
he but he made sure that they that you
couldn't live like it wasn't an Indian
building and a Malay building a Chinese
building he desegregated not just by
building and not just by floor by
apartment he wanted them to know each
other's kids and smell each other's
foods and stuff like that I tell people
and you put some of my Liberal
Democratic friends responsible to
Singapore it would still be a backwater
oh you can't force people live where
they don't want to live you can't you
know you can't punish people for
spitting on the streets you can't make
people in English that's what would
happen and so people have to think
policy Pot what works and what doesn't
work and so and by same thing with other
countries I just mentioned Germany's
vocational schools and Germany is doing
well in Europe and most of the country
countries aren't so you learn these
things when you go around the world
about what works and what doesn't and
you can write a books read about
Venezuela Ecuador Argentina Cuba North
Korea what did they do and largely
populism and you know the ones that
worked and South Korea no natural
resources unbelievable story Singapore
no natural resources unbelievable story
like I mean I can go on and on and on
about what works and what doesn't and
you know for some reason don't learn
these lessons I I worry about bad public
policy just causing constant damage out
there and you know beat when in America
you keep on hearing no productivities
low its secular stagnation it's a new
normal it's just not true oK we've we've
had multiple Wars okay we're not
educating our kids we had government
shutdowns badly spent money failures in
the health system failures in in an
extreme amount of regulation that's why
we're going slow it's not it's not that
the economic model and I just find with
people they just they looking for simple
answers and sometimes they aren't so all
these things are fixable
up next business has to have a seat at
the table
diamonds thoughts on the role business
should play in a new administration's
push for change
you
[Music]
in a new administration with a cast of
characters that is very different to
what we've seen in past administrations
is it possible you believe that it's
actually possible to sort of unite given
this extreme division and particularly
on issues like infrastructure that we've
tried to get in this country for two
decades now on tax reform talking about
regulation as well do you think that you
that you will be able to lead and that
business will take a bigger role and
saying look this needs to get done
business has to have a seat at the table
okay infrastructure isn't going to be
built properly that business advocacy at
the table it's cooling is not going to
happen if businesses don't work with
schools about what kind of jobs they
really need so yes I think business to
be a huge positive element in helping
design an infrastructure plan that both
Democrats and Republicans grita so what
happens in infrastructure oversimplify
this the Democrats spend money to spend
money just and of course you know we do
a lot of that and a lot of people feel
it just goes out to the bridges to
nowhere even Larry Summers wrote about
this bridge and Cambridge between
Harvard and Harvard Business School it's
a teeny little bridge five years being
rebuilt I'm its corruption folks don't
tell me it's not corruptions and people
buying up their local mayor's or friends
or unions or whatever they're doing it
something like that so the Democrats the
right we need infrastructure we don't
need it to create jobs you all remember
that famous Milton Friedman story Milton
Friedman was in Asia somewhere and
they're building the highway and they
have these big machines in the back but
they're all using shovels and he says
why are you using shovels why can't use
those machines it's not mr. Freeman it's
a great question jobs so Milton Friedman
said oh well in that case why don't you
use spoons you know and and that's kind
of the Democratic mentality it will
create jobs but if it's a bridge to
nowhere you're wasting your money if
it's a bridge to some we're not going to
create jobs in the short run it's
conducive to growth in the long run so
the Republic is a right to be questioned
how the money gets spent so that so they
if they're going to do it they're going
to want to say who's doing it how's it
being done is it probably spent there a
lot of ways to do that a lot of it by
the way it would be to give it back to
you know that this may or
was how to do it I mean we don't want
Washington the mayor what he needs he
knows what streets he needs what
streetlights you needs and you know the
hardest hit fund is helping you and so
there are things to be done I think
business can bridge that because we are
also watchful eye on on wasting money
going back to that Milton Friedman's
story do you think we've done a good
enough job and the president and other
and other figures now and explaining to
people that part of the fundamental
disruption that they're going through
that is disrupted your own industry is
this move to tack to automation that
some of those jobs that many of those
jobs including in in places like Detroit
and places where we saw a heavy swing in
this election western Pennsylvania Ohio
Michigan Wisconsin
you know where where I'm from that those
jobs are gone and they're likely not
coming back and training people for the
kinds of jobs the mid skill jobs the
upper skilled jobs equipping our next
generation of youth for those jobs are
we doing good in a job explaining that
to people in equipping them to be able
to succeed right so we're educating
people about something the wrong way
technology is the greatest they never
have the mankind okay until we had
agriculture we still would be hunting
Buffalo and living in tents okay and
agriculture allowed cities and
specialization specialization you know
created a knowledge the knowledge is
built on top of each other and create
institutions and you know we went from
fire to wheels to steam engines to you
know these wonderful phones we have in
our in our pocket now which can do
things that you could even imagine
doable that this is the reason that
mankind is living the way it lives today
okay so we have problem I'm not gonna
deny the problems we have but we
wouldn't be living the way our today my
grandfather was born there were no cars
1897 no cars no planes no healthcare you
got sick you died okay so now it's 120
years later and it's pretty good over
that time and mankind's gotten better
and better there's a book called the
better angels of our nature and it
actually analyzed things like people who
were murdered at the hands of other
people okay and that numbers been coming
down every single century for the last
20 centuries including last centuries
could ruler one in World War two I
believe this century so far is better
than last entry in spite away you read
the paper
and so the mankind is slowly learning by
hoping don't destroy yourself of nuclear
weapons but it's slowly learning
how to get better technology drives it
yes it's scary
it changes thing is disruptive we've
done a bad job to helping the disruptive
okay so what we need to do is this I say
we does not hold back technology this
use them improve mankind like people
worry about autonomous driving 40,000
people die a year in cars 40,000 people
you know I'm I'm just going to guess but
when we have a ton of driving I'll
probably 5,000 people it'll be a good
thing okay not a bad thing you know
Warren Buffett talks about 11 million
people working on farms you know 40 or
50 or 60 years ago and now it's a
million that's a good thing society
moved past that moves on you want people
going back to picking corn is that going
to make society better and you proves
you have a job not really mankind's
government for seven days a week to six
days a week to five days a week and I my
suspect were already down to about four
as I speak and and so we will adjust if
we need to adjust into no view and I
within running the government and all
the sudden you're going to 10,000 jobs
left in technology you and I would do
something to slow it down to retrain so
one of the problems in this retraining
this is not about youth now this is
about some losses well a good playing
job how do you deal with that but
because of technology or trade so you
know if you if a trucker loses a job he
doesn't want to go back to earning seven
dollars an hour he's got a family he
wants to live with dignity
there you can redevelop retrain and do a
bunch of things to make to ease that
issue and to make jobs available and
stuff like that I think it's doable so I
wouldn't stop it maybe you might slow it
down or modify how it's going to
function if it's causing too much
disruption in societies but this is why
I mean it's the counterpoint and I'm
glad you brought up trade you know that
people who feel that global trade has
hollowed out their community their
manufacturing their industry in the part
of the world where they grow up it's
very difficult to explain to people well
look yes globalization of Industry lifts
lifts boats lifts generally lifts the
boat higher but it may not have lifted
your boat because actually those jobs
have gone to more efficient
cost-efficient factories in Mexico
factories also where labor is cheaper
and they can get the product done just
as just as well that is a that is a
message that we see came and fly back in
in the election cycle this
we're across the world and people are
sort of saying resisting globalization
that is that as a trend that if it
deepens will be bad for business and
likely bad for your business look I
think if you there are issues where
globalization is unfair that so I mean I
won't go through the you know you could
say that steel or something like that
there are issues where it may have
caused disruption we didn't deal with it
properly hugely beneficial for mankind
hugely beneficial for United States
you're absolutely correct if it helps
ninety eight people maybe they're two
people really hurt so you're all getting
cheaper sneakers but someone lost the
job manufacturing sneakers now most
manufacturing jobs we've got from 20
million to 11 or 12
everyone estimates that 75% was
automation it was not jobs going
overseas an automation general has been
a good thing these were very some of
these are very tough jobs and so you
know mankind adjust again I would be in
favor of having proper trade fair trade
that's a legitimate thing as there
should be fair that helps America net
net net but where it does cause
something negative you know in the trade
bill and TPP this thing called trade
assistance adjustment or Trade
Adjustment Assistance where you which
specifically people can say this hurt my
community or my business and then get
relocation redevelopment retraining
income assistance all those things and
again you know the Democrats always
worry about that think it's improperly
done but the concept is very good I
think we need to find ways to broaden it
out so people say fine I understand
society's going to take care of me too
if I'm the net loser from this thing
coming up diamonds take on the minimum
wage I say if you were busy comport
raise it share the wealth a little bit
okay
you
[Music]
let's talk about regulation which you've
mentioned is one of the issues of policy
issues when I talk to people on the
street now and talk about regulation the
financial sector in particular and we
see what may be a rollback of certain
parts of whether it's dodd-frank whether
it's other elements of the CFPB or stuff
that's been brought in since the crisis
and there is concern that it will go
back to less regulated and in people's
minds less regulator means more risky
and that there will be no way to control
sort of the less the more esoteric
corners of the financial world and that
risk will migrate there and that there's
a real risk that if this regulation is
stripped back I know you think that
they've gone too far in certain respects
how do you see that debate playing over
over the next four years so you know
it's a legitimate thing for people to
say you don't want banks to Jeb know
JPMorgan didn't jeopardize a system we
did not cause the crisis we did not need
tarp and we have three times more
capital we had back then okay we didn't
lose much always how much I think we
lost in the nine quarters after the
Lehman crisis and people gets 5 million
10 billion we made 20 or 30 billion
dollars we were not jeopardizing anyone
in fact we helped we bought wha movie
book Bear Stearns we saved 30,000 jobs
in doing so we helped government city
schools state hospitals that probably
want to survive but for JPMorgan
stepping up to do some well so but I
understand the concept the American
public saw a disaster it wasn't their
fault and general it was Wall Street in
Washington and they absolutely have the
right to say we want a safe and sound
banking system it doesn't cost me money
and doesn't take down my economy those
are true that does not mean it's a false
lies they therefore all these rules and
regulations are good they're unrelated
so the American public's been told that
that you know whatever Bank wants don't
do it any know strengthen dodd-frank
that's not accurate okay some of these
things a lot of the things in dodd-frank
had nothing to do with the crisis I mean
zero nada they were just the pet peeves
of certain Democrats who just put things
ynx they felt like it someone said to me
once anything has the name of a Center
on it that was their bad part you know
like Barney Frank and I agreed and some
of the things that should have been in
there anytime you've done mage
legislation and major regulations and
they're different by the way it's
perfectly reasonable for people to look
back reanimate recalibrate think it
through talk about what it
with damage it did how we can help
befall folks we have not solved the
housing market mortgages because we
haven't solved that issue which is among
seven agencies or something like that
people are unbanked and others are
afraid to make mortgage the first-time
homebuyers self-employed or people who
had a prior bankruptcy now people have
probably bankruptcy eighty percent of
time is perfectly legitimate there's
nothing wrong with them it was usually
due to death divorce disease lost a job
not in one case was it you would say
there's a bad person they deserve a
second chance we haven't fixed that you
know you I would look at some of the
rules and regulations a reducing credit
available in the system but they do not
create more safety and soundness and I
don't want to bore you with the details
about that so dodd-frank isn't the Bible
okay and you know to me matter of fact
even Chuck Schumer used to say to me
look eventually these huge legislature
being opened up when we look at it
recalibrated synchronize it you know
reduce the negative parts of the cost
there's no benefit while still
accomplish the ultimate goal so it's a
perfectly reasonable thing to look at
these things and try to figure out what
you could do better as opposed as a
knee-jerk reaction everything was put in
place was good do you think the days
where people the industry essentially
has a Scarlet Letter on its back still
from the crisis he is our over or at
least fading the industry got a bad a
scarlet letter you know the state about
tarp I mean the second tarp happened
that was a scarlet letter not every bank
needed it but the rhetoric was all the
banks were bailed out they were not all
bailed out that part was not true no one
ever asked that question but that became
a scarlet letter no I don't think it's
going to go away for a long time and I
think all you can do is just earn your
stripes every single day by doing a good
job for every single client every single
community in every single city around
the world and you know that's my job I'm
very proud JPMorgan Chase I'm proud of
what we do when we accomplished how we
helped Society when we do make mistakes
we admit them and try to fix them so I
wanted thinking about that in terms of
we're approaching the end of the
president's eight years in office and
looking at sort of what he's
accomplished in his relationship with
business you've had a up and down
relationship with the administration if
you're being candid what grade letter
would you give him on his rating with
that with what he's done for business
I am NOT going to do that i i wished
they had spend more time having
conversation about what works and what
doesn't work and working with business
and not acting like business with the
opposite so today you hear the democrats
very often
i'm going to take care of you i'm going
to take care of you i'm going to take
care of you i'm going to take care of
you I'm going to take care I'm going to
give you a free education I'm going to
forgive you and and it's all it was
almost always like the person to go take
care of you from is us I just think it's
wrong okay I didn't think that whole
attitude is just is just misguided
sounds good is misguided I listen to
Bernie Sanders speak sometimes and you
know he wants to take care of he wants
medical insurance for everybody you want
pension benefits for everybody
he wants good-paying jobs for everybody
he wants education for everybody the
minimum wage we've been playing
Detroit's trying to is fifteen dollars
for teller we trained them we put two
hundred million dollars into them we pay
people well everyone who worked at
JPMorgan Chase's medical insurance so
that person making $15 an hour makes
$33,000 and medical worth ten thousand
if they have a family it's worth twenty
thousand they also get a pension and a
401k match okay so we I we do all those
things we train our people we take care
of our people we take care of our
communities we're doing exactly what it
sounds like I think you want a good
company to doing so
so sometimes Bernard together that you
know I'm sure Bernie's gonna love that
what do you see is this let's talk about
minimum IQ top of the press okay here's
the here's the American press
no one asked Bernie Sanders or Bernie
says supporter during the whole campaign
I saw what is socialism and how is it
done elsewhere
well I there are two answers it's never
done well elsewhere it's been a disaster
and socialism is where the state owns
all private enterprise that's what it is
what do you think some would ask is that
what do you think people have voted for
that yeah next time I see a mo
um but talking about minimum wage that's
been one of your big pushes and you
believe it's vital to growth as well and
as you said you've moved up at JPMorgan
we now have a Labour nominee for labor
secretary who's been one of the most
open advocates against raising the
minimum wage and has been quite firm
about that I I don't think so because I
would I read this what he said is that
the government should be very care about
raising its minimum wage too high it
should be a decision made a local level
because you all you know a lot of
businesses you know could afford
California New York can afford $15 in
New York City but upstate New York
probably can't okay so I think was
saying that he's not against states
raising it thoughtfully that can help
people I'm kind of in favor that I would
be non fare the federal government's
doing it and imposing real hardships but
the other thing is if if you can afford
it I say if you're a business can afford
raise it share the wealth a little bit
okay I tell the people JP more worried
about the pay of our lower paid people
than our higher paid people you know so
but the other thing is to help societies
the Earned grab tax credit that's that's
my example is that will help small
business so if you're a small business
that needs wages at $10 an hour to get
by and you can't afford medical so I'm
not saying you're a bad person but
that's how you survive then this this
will really help you you can attract
better people to be paid more you're
probably less attrition and allow your
for maybe afford more benefits over time
so there are solutions to this and us
raising is just a teeny piece of it
I want to make this place better I'm
going to give it everything I was going
on here a peek into the future at
diamonds hopes for his legacy at
JPMorgan Chase that's up next
you
[Music]
when you look at the world as it is
shaping up right now and when you look
at this administration what are the
things that concern you what are the
what are both the things I concern you
and what are the possible Black Swan
events that we could see that would be
truly disruptive if you look at the
geopolitical trends and one of our
cousins made a list of all the big ones
since World War two Korea Vietnam five
Milanese crises to Afghanistan to Iraq
Iran Iraq China had a border skirmish
with Russia India and Pakistan China and
Vietnam I'm missing a whole bunch only
one ever derailed the global economy the
others had in fact like Vietnam had a
huge effect for a long period of time
but only one and there's a 1973 millions
crisis the real the economy so
geopolitics is always very noisy very
really hazard effect I think it's a
little worse because I always say where
is it kind of from normal friction is it
better worse philo worse a lot of wars
in the Middle East you know more and
more uncertainty around nuclear it's I
think is one of the greatest risks that
our threats are going to threaten
mankind and that's both Iran Russia and
North Korea North Korea is going to has
a bomb and they're soon to be able to
deliver it all the way to California
okay it's not my assessments the
assessment of top people and they might
you know in the government they might
have that to two years or so okay those
are that's a serious issue for the world
but I worry obviously about that and you
know peace in the Middle East but in
reality by worried about the most is bad
policy bad policy I was doing things
that make it worse you know like
government shutdowns and failures here
and not fixing the school system because
if you want populism you want to get
worse don't fix the school system grow
the economy slower that would be worse
for the world than almost anything else
and the world needs a strong America an
America I remind bill our military might
and the military is unbelievable you
serve the military god bless you for
doing it's unbelievably always the
highest regard it's directly related to
our economic might so we better be
really careful about the vibrancy of
this economy and make sure we have that
because that is the solution to a lot of
these geopolitical issues too if the
world needs a strong America does the
world need in America that's closer to
Russia you know look geopolitics is
different than friendship
okay so when you say that so you know
we're going to go hug Russia there are
serious issues with Russia they should
be dealt with very seriously I think
they're kind of resolvable you know and
so but I don't know that I'm not an
expert in that you know we obviously do
business there and but but if you made I
would put that on the list of things
that should be done so my own view we
should have a very strong relationship
with NATO NATO has been dramatically
weakened all these years dramatically
okay and American troops should be side
by side both in the Middle East and in
na it takes place in Europe to defend
Europe side by side with you know
British French German Italian troops not
just American boys out there okay so and
bye-bye it's exactly what Donald Trump
is talking about you listen to them and
then that group the transatlantic group
should offset a putin and all that means
is is that he can't go anywhere that's
in the EU and I think that my own view
and I'd listen to Henry kitchen I won't
go through it you can have a negotiated
settlement of Ukraine and it's probably
doable at one point so I you know after
that I don't think Putin wants to pick a
fight I think he wants to get rid of
sanctions I think he wants to he wants
to become important the world he wants
to be an accepted lead around the world
so we'll see what happens with Russia
but I think it's a serious issue right
now when you look at them when we look
at there's been a lot of reshuffling in
the banking industry even in the recent
weeks and leadership and you're not
going to be the Treasury secretary now
you will be involved in advising
administration when you think of your
own legacy and looking forward with
Detroit very much a part of it as well
what is it that you want to be
remembered for what is it that you want
to have achieved winter when I was a
young CEO former CEO the company came to
see me and said you've got to make a
mark leave your legacy do one big thing
I said like what are you talking about
he said like you know build
international or whatever and I think of
a CEO talked about one thing sell the
stock okay because we got to do it all
right just like the mayor's doing here
you got it
I got a systems right technology right
culture right people right I got to do
it right in every country you know it's
a I get the whole mosaic right right
fail so the one thing I wanted to say
we're going to miss that son-of-a-bitch
the world where the hopefully the world
is better off for him and and the shows
are better off he made this a better
place and that's it I'm not looking for
any other major like you know like JP
Morgan Chase already I am so damn proud
of my company by the way I want to know
that I am proud of our people we do
every day
it's got unbelievable capabilities I
want to make sure that this is still one
of the best banks in the world in 20
years and so I'm just I'm just proud to
be part of the place is there gonna be a
second act after you leave when you
leave any hint I don't I'm Jimmy Lee who
passed away when my great friends and
partners said to me one day you know Jim
you could do one last big thing like
what he said like turn around a GM for
the government it's not like that I said
are you kidding me this isn't for me I
live and breathe JPMorgan Chase
I wear this jersey it's not about my
comp it's not if I tells the board you
know so you say don't tell aboard that
but I really mean it makes no difference
to me I want to make this place better
and I'm going to give it everything as
long as I'm here and when I'm no longer
but if I can't give all I got I should
move on you I can help do stuff but I
shouldn't be the CEO if you're going to
be the quarterback or the head coach you
got to give it your all there's nothing
else you can do and so when I leave here
know I'll probably I'll probably teach a
little bit I may write I may write a
book IV I've been through a lot I have a
lot to share I think at one point and
teach get involved in business I've
never been a I have been on board but
not any boards they go to public company
board a company I like the people in the
product and going to not-for-profit now
I'll probably I'm lazy so I'll probably
go to New York City maybe join or start
an entrepreneur color fund I'm gonna
have a gasps I mean a lot of stuff I
will not run another major big company
okay last question then if Donald Trump
did call you up in a year's time in two
years time if we did see the economy
teetering a bit if we felt like these
were something back into recession would
you take that call would you join him I
will I would never not take a call from
the President on States of America and
listen he has to say
and considering has to say so that's my
that again I don't think I'm suited for
it now if you somehow convince me I'm
the only one who could do something like
that I would consider patriotic duty I
doubt that's ever gonna be the case
layer up and Ted
I would take the call I don't I don't
think would happen
[Music]